wanted to have them on to talk about the
conflicting advice they give to women
um because you always hear so often in
the mana sphere like
like obviously body count is important
you want to grow with a low body count
that's fine but they also say like don't
if a girl doesn't sleep with you on a
third date
like
not to deal with her and i'm like i
think you're gonna have a hard time with
both because when i think of three dates
that's like not that much time with
someone like if i just met you off an
app or like met you in person that's
like
what one two three four like 12 hours
maybe total you've talked about yeah
like that's really not that much time
and it just like really depends on the
type of like life you want to win if you
just want to live on like that you know
new woman every day sort of like protect
potential bachelor of life that's
i guess completely fine at least in a
short term before
you highlight the chance of catching
something
but it's like i don't know if you want a
so-called like another term that's
thrown away like a high quality woman
like third date is
more often that's gonna be way too soon
so it's like
yeah
and i mean i think like you're right for
the bachelor lifestyle if they're like
trying to get um
like a bunch of different girls or
whatever i think that's
like that probably does make sense to
get rid of the girl after the third date
but
if you're looking if you're looking for
a wife i'm not
i just say like three dates that's
really not that much time
um
i mean unless you like knew them before
maybe i guess but like
yeah even though
like that's really only like how long
how long do dates go like when i have a
because i'm thinking like with someone i
don't know that's gonna be like four
hours at most would you say
like if you did like if you did like
dinner and like
um someone else is here
yeah that's fine i don't mean a monopoly
so it's
[Music]
hi parole can you hear me yeah i can
hear you hey how's it going
i'm good how are you i'm good
how's england
good i love it here so um
i don't know how old
both of you are
because the guy was just talking about
for three days isn't enough
when you're older
you don't have a lot well you're two
true professionals and you're trying to
find the time
like the older you get the faster you
you have to show intent
and when you're the man and you're
paying for the dates and courting a
woman the most the fastest way that she
can show interest while you're showing
and i can't hear that guy for dates it's
for her it's for her to have sex with
you
so and also as as people get older men
and women generally know what they want
faster
so
how old are you
you're 40 are you married
i was married
okay so i was just curious if you're
okay i was just curious if you were
still like in the dating game if that's
what you're speaking from every woman
including including my ex-wife
because men get to know
women
first how to have
to have sex with them
you a man will not get to know a woman
in a relationship way until he's had sex
with her
i'm sorry
yeah you could roll your eyes off i
could say something i could say
something to that
like it's interesting because my like i
didn't have sex with my last boyfriend
or my boyfriend now tell like we were
dating
like
how many
if it looks like i'm rolling my eyes
sorry i'm just trying to think and like
how long are we dating for is that you
said
um
let's see i met him
first week of december we started dating
two weeks later and then we like we
didn't have sex for like a month until
after that see but that's like a month
like
when yeah when you're a professional and
you're doing online dating you can talk
for weeks before you meet in person
and then
like
if you're if you're a professional
i'm i'm uh
well it was nice because we were
youtubers so we like literally like just
like
yeah and
you have a life
maybe you meet like one date and then
two weeks later you go on another date
or like
five or six or seven eight days go by so
like
three days can be a month or two i
understand what i'm saying
so yeah but to me it's like it's like
the time you spend with them though like
that's like
like on my end it's like even if there's
been a couple dates that went by like i
didn't spend it with you
you know
no i mean
like on average when i'm when i'm online
dating
it
there's usually at least a week or two
between dates between dates okay and
that's
normally if we're talking like a nine to
five person that has a life and
activities that's how long it goes so
when they were talking three days i
think that you're talking about uh
in the context of monday tuesday
wednesday no it's like yeah yeah we have
to find time to see each other on
saturday and then like i might not see
you again one of the reasons why people
online date
is one
if a woman has a dating profile it means
i'm available because we can't approach
women in public anymore or at work
yeah
that is very true are available so i can
approach you number one
number two
i don't have time to troll bars and go
to places and look for tail and a lot of
professional women are the same way too
they have lives and careers so that they
can't just go to a bar and close out at
two o'clock
that is fun
so do you do you care about a girl's
body count does that not matter to you i
i don't care about a girl's body count i
don't date single mothers and
and
and i don't date big women
and the reason why why i don't date
large women it isn't it isn't because of
the physical part that's the second to
it
i've never been heavy but i've been
uncomfortable
with the body i was in enough where i
was absolutely miserable and i don't
date larger women because
the the mental conversations
that they're having with themselves
and the insecurities
that they have
their their partner is going to have to
pay for it there's no reason why you
should ever ask me
do i look big in this dress
i'm not standing for that
so
people think that i don't
because
yeah they're not physically attractive
big people particularly the bigger women
you can't say anything mean
to large women because
it reminds them of the conversations
that they have with themselves late at
night when they're looking up at the
ceiling in bed or looking at themselves
in the mirror
and
you're gonna have to pay for that it's
the same thing as like a woman
dating a broke guy
a lot of times a broke guy is going to
make his issues with her making more
money than him her problem
oh i had a friend like that her
boyfriend would always like mention how
she made more money than him yeah like
it wasn't even like she didn't even care
but it was like he kept bringing it up
yeah
i just wanted to say pearl like one of
the biggest things with your channel
is um
first off it's great to talk to you
um
is
there's a disc
and i think you've seen a taste of it
because you you know donovan sharp or
you've been on like fresh and fit but
like
you have no idea
like so there's the manosphere and then
there's the the black manosphere
okay and
black men we have a whole different
a whole different set of problems
separate from any other group of men
because our
our culture is a matriarchy
okay okay
are you rolling your eyes again or is it
just a thing
no
oh i'm sorry yeah i'm just
wait
i wasn't rolling my eyes no no not you
i'm talking the other guy oh okay no
sorry i'm just uh if i seem a bit off
i'm just i'm just taking down notes and
i often just like look up to see
i know i i agree for the most part so
that's we're all completely good so
sorry for being disrespectful i know
you're saying you can understand you
know i i've seen you talk to richard
cooper
and all these different guys
but
you
you're on the outside looking in
but i think i can see you kind of
interconnected with the regular
manosphere where you're kind of so
disconnected from the black manosphere
and the experience of black men when it
comes to like black women in general
and i'm hoping that somehow you can get
a better understanding of that because
i've been on this planet for
for 40 years i have a graduate degree
i'm i'm a professional you know you know
i'm i'm well into the middle
six figures and
i um
i hear like people like kevin
samuels they speak he speaks for
you know the
the the black men like me who
um
the earlier part of my life you know
because i was educated i spoke a certain
way like i couldn't it wasn't until i
was 35 that i was able to regularly date
african-american women
because i'm single i don't have any kids
you know i
i broke the six figure barrier and i'm
one of those guys where now that i'm 40
i can take my pick and if you would have
told me
when i was 25 that i have the options i
have now all i have to do is stay
childless
get get a
graduate degree and get some money and
so
it's just i'm hoping that you can get a
better understanding as to where black
men come from because in my opinion you
can't group black men and black men as a
whole into the patriarchy because we
don't have anything
with at least linked to the least
educated the least
every measure of benefit of the
patriarchy black men in general we don't
benefit from we just don't yeah
part of the patriarchy we suffer in
silence our you know like
i when i say the majority i say 51
50 the majority of our women
like i remember
like
the majority of our women are not on our
side and we have to make it out here by
ourselves mm-hmm so what do you
like i see your content and i i see you
working to be interconnected with the
regular manosphere when i see you
commenting on stuff like kevin samuels
and and you know
and and you know kind of the black
menosphere it's just i just wish that
there's a way that you could be more
cognizant of the struggles that
that
it's like
one of the biggest
disconnects is
black women
one of the normal expectations of dating
a black woman is you know the their list
of regulars include
respect me as a boss
you know uh you know have a job be six
foot tall and accept my children
no other wow no other group of men is
expected to accept another man's
children um
you should accept my children
and you're not a real me no other group
of men has to suffer from their
i don't understand how these girls get
pregnant so much to be honest you can
get like an iud and be good
like it's not you get an iud once you're
good like you know how hard it is to get
pregnant with an iud it's like yeah but
nine point like
that's pretty rare but they keep it a
stack um
and
the communities i guess you could say
that it often happens around i mean a
lot of these chicks are in um what's uh
what's it called medic medicaid and i'm
not sure if that covers an idea
yeah but there's still like there's
still condoms you can track yourself
here's the thing
it it it starts way before that
no one can tell these women anything it
starts with that
mm-hmm what do you think is do you think
that's because um a lack of like like
you said it's a matriarchy so would you
say it's like a lack of like fathers in
the home or like father is that what
you're saying it is
this is just my honest belief uh well
i think that's it but it's just
um
i'm just gonna use this as an example
what's your name
mac
yeah schmuck um
you're african-american right
yeah i i know i look crazy but i'm just
i'm home from school and
looking at you sort of
oh yeah my fifth year hopefully lost so
do you have a job
oh yeah i work as a stagehand right now
so make around 16 hour minimum if this
has been your experience
but in my life and a professional and
academic setting
my worst enemy isn't a white person it's
usually it's usually another black
person
yeah that's true
that's true because they're loud they're
obnoxious and no one can tell them
anything
and this is from like
when they're younger it's like people
let black women act a certain way
and so it gets to them
so yeah